[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAKSHMI SHARMA: Hello, everyone.
My name is Lakshmi Sharma.
I'm Director of
Product Management
for Networking at Google Cloud.
And I have the pleasure of
talking to Eric Hanselman.
He's the chief analyst
at 451 Research.
And we are going to talk about
what hybrid means to customer,
and what are their pain points?
What are their drivers?
And what are the tools that
are available for making
their journey to hybrid
easy as well as less risky?
Over to you.
ERIC HANSELMAN: Oh.
Thanks, Lakshmi.
Going to kick this off.
Ah, technology.
We're moving forward.
So I wanted to touch on
the morning's keynotes.
Hopefully most of you saw them.
Urs was talking about
enterprises need to transform
and some of the challenges
that they're facing simply
because of market pressures,
customers' demands,
a whole set of different
pieces that are really
forcing a need to transform.
And what we're going
be talking about today
is really some statistics about
what's driving some of that,
but also some of
the capabilities
that can help move that forward.
Technology is not
standing still,
which is an advantage
generally, but can also be a--
generate a little
bit of risk in terms
of concerns about what's
the right path forward
and how to really look at this.
If we think about movement
to new capabilities
and infrastructure,
there's tremendous desire.
Everybody wants to
get to a better place.
Whether or not that happens
to be peaches and sunsets,
new capabilities in terms
of infrastructure or cloud
developments, whatever
that happens to be,
there's a lot of push
to be able to get there.
I think we all as
humans want to be
able to move towards a
better place, whatever
that capability is.
Exactly how they
get there and what
they're doing to make
those transitions happen,
though, are really
changing very dramatically
in terms of what enterprises
are expecting today.
And I wanted to
bring up some data.
451 has a broad study.
We have about a 60,000
participant panel
that are looking at
transitions in technology,
budgetary intent, spending.
And this is the
data that I'm going
to be talking about today.
This happens to be from
our Voice of the Enterprise
digital pulse about
transitions and on-prem data.
And the thing that's--
the desire part of this
is, if you look at today,
half of the respondents are
identifying that between 3/4
and all of their infrastructure
is on-prem today.
And about another quarter
have about half to 3/4.
So that's a really
large population
that are primarily on-prem and
probably that's not a surprise
to most of you, hopefully not.
The thing I think it's
interesting from the desire
perspective is you look at where
their expectations about where
they want to get
to in two years.
We're talking about a
pretty dramatic change
in terms of capabilities,
both in what's on-prem today
and what they expect
to be able to move out.
Again, from an
aspirational perspective,
you know there's
that desire to be
able to get to
better infrastructure
to be able to manage
your resources better.
It's a key part of what some
of those shifts are looking at.
But it's a pretty
dramatic shift.
In order to do this,
enterprises are really
going to need a whole
set of capabilities
that they may not have today.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: And that's fair.
Like an infrastructure
like what we have at Google
in the networking
space, we're talking
about migrating loads of data
in two years like the number
shows.
So capabilities
like interconnect
that we have, the
amount of fiber
that we have put in
any part of the world.
So those capabilities may be
useful for those customers,
because you are migrating
workloads, migrating data,
so you would need
that infrastructure
support to do that.
ERIC HANSELMAN: Well, and as you
start to expand into new areas,
it's not only just
the migration part.
But it's all those paths
to data that you've
got to maintain once you're
starting to move once,
you're in the middle
of that transition,
and into whatever next
state you wind up getting.
So interconnection winds
up being really critical.
It's something that
I think, generally,
in the move to the
early stages of cloud,
enterprises really haven't
fully understood precisely how
important that is.
We've all dealt with
VPN connections,
and then internet access
to be able to manage it,
but in order to get enterprise
capable performance,
you have to have
interconnection that's
going to be dependable
enough to be
able to manage this transition.
LAKSHMI SHARMA:
That's interesting.
I joined Google six months ago.
And it's very interesting
to hear when people say,
oh, network is seamless.
And that's exactly you
want customers to see--
it's secured, and it's
seamless, and it's just
connecting you where you
want, bringing network to you,
bringing cloud to you.
That's what we do in
cloud infrastructure.
Even with geoexpansions
and all the expansions
that we do in every
part of the world,
we continue to add more fibers.
We have 13 subsea
cables that we have.
We have 125 PoP locations.
We have loads of dedicated
interconnection and with SLA.
So I believe there are
no other companies that
offer that kind of SLA
for interconnect exactly
for the reason that we believe
that if its network has
to be there, performant,
and being able to give you
the guarantees that
you need in order
to migrate your workloads, in
order to migrate your data.
So yep.
ERIC HANSELMAN: Well,
and that seamless piece
is what's important, because
enterprise has traditionally
been used to buy
capacity discretely.
I'm going to buy circuits.
I'm going to buy links.
I'm going to buy ports,
all these pieces.
It's being able to actually
take that capability
and bring it into an environment
that is much easier to use
and easier to consume
that helps reduce risk.
The other piece that I wanted
to identify that I thought
was interesting about
this transition,
if you look at what
this transition is going
to look like, when you
think about how that's going
to be consumed, this is a
breakdown of expectations
of where enterprises are--
how they're expecting
to move workloads
and how they're expecting
to manage that movement.
The top, the
modernized piece there,
is really taking a look at--
easy for me to say--
expecting that they're
going to take their existing
environments, run them
on-prem, and then start
to be able to bring
modern applications.
So this is mobile apps that wrap
around stuff that's on-prem.
That's a good first step.
But it's also, again, one
of these low risk first step
enterprise strategies.
The second, that's a
good step down from that,
though, but I think it's one
of the more critical pieces,
is refactoring and
shift, being able to take
key aspects of those
business applications,
refactoring what makes
sense, basically pulling
out some of those
key value functions,
and being able to take those
into the new infrastructure,
wherever that winds up being.
The next beyond that
is repurchasing shift.
That's just simply we're
going to go take capabilities
that somebody else has got and
we're going to run it that way.
We're going to manage
them simply in that way.
Lift and shift is one of those
pieces that, for a long time,
I think was expected to be the
primary way enterprise would go
forward, we just take the
application, we pick it up,
we bring it into
cloud, colocation,
whatever it happens to be.
But enterprises have understood
that now that's actually--
that's a little more
complex than originally it
was planned to be.
It is an area, though,
that we think about what
that transition looks like.
It can make a lot of sense for
large, monolithic functional
elements.
So if we think about
things like databases,
big pieces of that
nature, those can
be places where that
functionality actually
makes sense to migrate closer
to where you expect it to be,
so sources of data, management
systems, or sources of truth.
That can be a big transition.
It can be useful there.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: So that's
an interesting one.
So let's say for
databases, do you
hear that those
databases will still
be managed by the database
providers or the IT teams,
or where do you see the
manageability aspect?
ERIC HANSELMAN:
It's a transition,
so there's a big piece
of the management,
of the operational management,
that I think if enterprises
could hand that off to a trusted
partner who is managing it,
would make a lot of sense.
In some cases, they
simply want to make sure
that all of that
functionality moves over.
But they don't want to carry
with all of the management
tasks that come with it.
That can be a real challenge.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: So there are
certain things we are doing,
and some of you if you plan
to attend keynotes tomorrow
and the networking sessions,
they will be talking about some
of the managed aspects and
how do we bring manageability
and the latency
and the throughout
that we offer through
our infrastructure.
So please, I would encourage you
to attend the keynote session
tomorrow where you will hear
a lot of things around this.
ERIC HANSELMAN:
Well, especially when
you get to newer
technologies like transitions
into analytics infrastructure,
things like building out
Hadoop clusters, the management
of any of these pieces
can be a challenge
and especially when
there are already difficulties
in making sure that you've got
sufficient staff to be
able to manage them.
That can help to free
up existing staff
to be able to leverage
the high value
capabilities, the
use of the analytics,
as opposed to having to spend
a lot of time adding staff
to manage the actual
operational piece.
You know, enterprises
want the functionality.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: So in the
refactor and modernize,
we talk a lot about
microservices.
And a lot of our customers
come to us for help with that.
Many of you would
know our efforts
in Istio and
Kubernetes and the work
that we're doing in that space.
We have a lot of sessions
coming up around that area too.
So we hear a lot of customers
moving towards microservices.
And we do take pride in the
fact that we launch billions
of containers every
week in Google Cloud,
like new Kubernetes
came out of Borg.
And that's how we run
our infrastructure.
So how do you-- what
kind of applications
do you see when you think
about modernizations?
And do you, from a
refactoring perspective,
do you see customers first
refactoring and trying
them on-prem and then
moving to managed,
lets say, cloud,
or do you expect
to see a management
across hybrid cloud?
ERIC HANSELMAN:
Well, there's got
to be-- from an
operational perspective,
you've got to have some
level of unified management
across that entire environment.
I mean the ideal, you know
that sandy beach that people
are trying to get to, is
an equivalent capability
across all of the
different execution venues
that you've got and to
be able to manage that
with the same set of tools
across that environment.
I think for a lot
of enterprises,
they expect that to be a
nirvana they just can't get to,
because they've been used
to treating the cloud
infrastructure differently
than the way in which they
run what they've got on-prem.
And that can present
some real challenges
in terms of your mobility
and workload mobility.
It's really hard to be able
to do that shift effectively.
If you've got different
management capabilities,
you've got to run and
operate differently
in terms of where
those capabilities are.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: Very good.
ERIC HANSELMAN: In terms
of the applications,
where we see a lot
of those directions
really is across the map.
There's some vertical variation
that we see by industry,
but the expectation
to get towards
a re-architected environment
that can better take advantage
is a very strong piece of that.
But again, that's
some variability
in terms of where that
all gets directed.
We want to keep this
interactive and I
wanted a quick show of hands.
In terms of the lift
and shift capabilities,
for folks who are here from
the enterprise side of things,
how many of you are expecting
to be able to fully refactor
any of your key business apps?
Quick show of hands.
A handful here and there.
Again, probably where are we--
about 18%, maybe a little less.
How many of you are
expecting to be able to build
net new in new infrastructure?
LAKSHMI SHARMA: Wow.
ERIC HANSELMAN: Yeah.
So one of the things that I tend
to see maybe a little stronger.
You're here at Next.
You're probably a
little more cloud aware
in terms of what your directions
are and where you're headed.
Another data point
that I thought
was particularly
interesting in all of this
is the shift to what those
infrastructures are actually
going to look like.
And we start thinking about
what the transitions--
yes, people are
getting off-prem,
but where are they
actually heading
and what are those expectations?
Today, again, most of the
infrastructure that enterprise
is working with is on-prem.
No big surprise there.
There is a reasonable amount
of on-prem private cloud
capability today, a bit
of hosted private cloud,
not a lot in terms of what
the general breakdown is,
a fair amount of use of
SaaS and co-location.
Again, co-location.
A lot of cases
we've got folks who
are looking to move systems
into environments where they've
got better connectivity,
maybe transitioning out
of existing data
center environments.
A couple of big steps there.
And of course, a reasonable
amount of public cloud use.
But again, if we look at
what that total enterprise
picture is, traditional,
full blown public cloud
for line of business operations,
real serious production
applications, is
still relatively low.
A sub 10% number is something
that we see pretty broadly.
My guess is, here
at Next, there's
probably a little more use of
direct public cloud capability
in whatever that capacity is.
But the thing, though, that
I think is more important
is what the
transition looks like
and to be able to move towards
a doubling of utilization
of public cloud
capabilities again
is going to require
a significant amount
of transition for enterprise.
And I think that's
one of the places,
to your question
about management
and the orchestration
pieces of this, that's
where there's going to need to
be a very large step in terms
of how enterprise
is really working
with those capabilities.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: This
is very interesting.
So although it says that
on-prem infrastructure is
going to be half of
what it is today,
but it's distributed across.
It seems like, based
on the current results,
enterprises will still contain
the hierarchies and the orgs
and the rules and the
policies, and then they
would be distributing it across.
So something on
policy management,
like centralized policy
management keeping--
how is the security?
Won't the control for security
going to be more distributed?
ERIC HANSELMAN: Absolutely.
Well, I think
that's the challenge
is that, for a lot of
organizations, once they start
to be able to spread
into new environments,
it's great to have the
ability to have scaling
capacity, whatever
those drivers are,
to be able to get
them to those points.
The challenge is to be able
to take all of the people
and processes that
have been running
the organization for however
long and actually transition
them into an environment in
which they can take advantage
of hybrid capability.
There are a set of
different aspects
that are going to start
to come into play.
We already see it
today with concerns
about data sovereignty,
what do I put where, where
is the data that's
going to be actually--
that this app is consuming
going to be delivered from?
What do I need to
do with the results?
Where can I run analytics?
How do I balance all that stuff?
That presents a whole
set of new challenges
that, for most
enterprises, they haven't
had to deal with before.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: So this is--
here I will kind of bring
in some of the tools
that we are offering, and
there are two talks around
this today.
So we had been hearing
similar things,
that, hey, we have these
identity management systems,
and we use this identityware
proxies and on-prem.
And then we go to the cloud.
Then we are using
managed services from,
let's say, from Google.
So we are using your
GCS managed services.
And so we are coming
from cloud public side.
We are coming from on-prem
through private services.
How do we manage all
those access, right?
How do we integrate them into
a common, say, policy framework
so that we continue to use
the GCP resources, say, which
are in VPCs, and we can have
a mapping of the identities,
whether it is device
identity or IP range,
and we can still protect
the data exfiltration, which
may happen because of
existing roles, which we're
able to access the GCS buckets?
So we put in all
of that together
in something called
VPC service control.
So you can bring your
identity or their proxies.
You can put your policies
right at the VPC level.
We have like host-based
firewalls and things like that.
So you combine both of them.
And then you can bring in all
the context, like who you are,
where you're coming from, what
time of day you're coming from.
So with this distributed kind
of access of the resources,
tools like that
and automation like
that becomes very
important, right?
So those are the things
we had been hearing too.
So it's kind of matched to
what you just described.
ERIC HANSELMAN: Well, it
helps that to manage what
is that growing complexity.
The reality is when
you make that shift,
you're now in
multiple environments.
And just by nature, it's
going to be more complex.
What that demands is
that you have tools
to be able to leverage that.
I got a ghost that keeps
shifting these forward here.
Either that, or somebody
really wants to jump ahead.
And the enterprise
challenge is figuring out
how do you actually live in
that world in which you now
have got a whole set of more
distributed environments
with diverse characteristics.
How do you manage
it in the same way?
Because some of
those big challenges
are being able to take
the staff you've got--
you know, in transitions like
this I don't think enterprise
is out there
expecting that they're
going to radically increase
the amount of staff they've
got to manage it.
So they've got to
have simplifications
that can help to not only
make the orchestration
and management
piece a lot simpler,
but to reduce some of that
risk and that transition.
The point that you're
making about security
is right at the top
of this list in terms
of how you manage and control.
Being able to integrate
identity is something
that most organizations have
had a hard time with to date.
I think that's one of the more
powerful tools and capabilities
to have at your disposal,
to be able to transform
what was, you know, a
lot of those functional
perimeter-based capabilities
that on-prem were
OK and manageable, but once you
start to get out into a more
distributed environment,
it can really
create complexities that are
hard to get your hands around
from an operational perspective.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: You brought up
the product name and the terms
like we do call it
service parameter,
where if you kind of
put in all the VPC
resources and [INAUDIBLE].
So, yeah, and on the people
side too, I was in India, like,
there was a Cloud Summit
in India a few weeks ago.
And the point that you
touched upon about, like,
will each organization
go and hire these people?
Like, it's not just
about data scientists.
It's about, like, just the
whole manageability, automation,
orchestration, and
understanding different clouds.
Yeah, so we hear from like
financials, and retail,
and across the board
in this region,
as well as in Asia
region, that, yes,
it's so difficult
to hire those people
and then kind of train them
on enterprise practices,
while you are training--
while they are already
bringing kind of engineering.
But we do need to kind
of bring in a blend
of how organizational
structure and how
those policies and
organizational environment
are done.
So the tools like being
able to kind of apply
education that comes
from understanding
IT infrastructure,
bringing to the cloud,
and applying that
back through our tools
like hierarchical policy,
like our folder projects.
So we have been doing
that next, and we have
been hearing from customers.
It's not easy to
just go and hire
those people who can just
do same thing across all
the IT organizations.
So it kind of ties in to
the point that you said.
Yes, it's not easy to just
do each of them for each IT
organization.
That's why we're trying
to build that experience
of understanding
enterprise organization
while we are bringing in
technology innovation.
ERIC HANSELMAN: Well,
transitions are a huge help.
Staffing has always been
a particular problem,
but especially as
you start going
to new levels of
complexity, that
can really present some
additional challenges.
One of the things I
wanted to touch on
are some of the drivers, what's
actually motivating people
to be able to make these shifts.
An interesting point
in some of this data--
it used to be, the
original idea about cloud,
is people are going to go to
cloud because it was cheap.
You know, cloud is going to
be the path to reduced cost,
and this is going
to be wonderful.
Well, you know, what we've seen
over the course of the last,
oh, this is a
particular study that's
been running now for a little
over five years for us,
is that reality is
starting to finally appear.
And people are understanding
that while cost
may be a component,
cost really shouldn't
be the primary driver.
And if you look now, this
is one of the first times
in this study that
we're actually
starting to get
pretty close to parity
with some of the more
important and valuable drivers.
Cost management can
be a huge benefit.
But it's one of those
things that if you're just
trying to target that
alone, you miss out
on so many other benefits, what
that transition can look like.
And those next three that are
down there that are close,
grouped fairly closely--
enhancing agility, improving
access to new technology,
modernizing the IT
infrastructure--
are all some of those
principle drivers
that we see about the
directions of new infrastructure
management.
Let's get back there.
The shark will appear,
but not just yet.
One of the big challenges in
terms of helping organizations
move this forward,
one of the things
that we wind up doing from
an analyst perspective,
is really helping
them align what
they're trying to
move towards and what
those capabilities are.
Agility, of course,
is a big one,
being able to move
to scale rapidly,
being able to manage
some of those shifts
in terms of managing
infrastructure with demand,
being able to be a little more
flexible in terms of where
your resources are, how
your infrastructure actually
gets built, and what
it actually costs
you can be one of the
biggest benefits in terms
of moving to hybrid environments
that let you pick and choose.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: And all of
this if we could do, like, you
know, yes, reduced IT costs
seems to be a little lower.
But they still hear
a customer-- they
do want to understand what
the TCO looks like, right?
Reducing cost is one thing, but
the overall operational cost,
right, so if you're going
from the VM to containers,
do I have to use
different tools?
Do I have to retrain
my organization?
So you talked about this
construct called VPC.
Do I have to have a
different paradigm just
to go to continuous rate?
If you go from K8 on-prem
to GKE, or you know,
Google's Kubernetes
Engine, do I have
to understand different
things about load balancing?
Do I have to--
will the VM load
balancing be different?
So we do hear all of them
because, like you said,
those three things about
modernizing IT infrastructure,
like, how you're modernizing
the infrastructure
all the way from what--
you know, whether it will
be bare metal, or VM,
or container.
And then how you will
be improving access,
which goes back to the--
you know, I'm used to accessing
resources through private IP.
Are you going to tell me that
my IP address management would
be different, right?
And will it be different
in different regions?
Do I have to connect different?
So we hear all of that, and
that becomes TCO for us.
Does that kind of make sense,
like operationalization
and all of it?
ERIC HANSELMAN: Absolutely.
I mean, again, getting
back to people and process.
So much of what the
transition is to new models,
whether or not they
happen to be a hybrid
or simply revamping the
capabilities that you have
already, are being able to
ensure that you can actually
bring the rest of the
organization along with you
when you get there.
Some of that starts with
development process.
But a big part of it has to
be the operational environment
that's going to support it.
If your dev teams are getting
way out ahead in terms
of what their requirements
are, but you can't provide that
from an operational
perspective, that's just as much
of a problem as, you know,
if you can't build and ship
product.
It's a challenge.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: Sorry.
ERIC HANSELMAN: I was going to
say, from a dev perspective,
I wanted to get
another quick poll.
How many of you would identify
that your organizations are
doing a DevOps CI/CD kind of
development process today?
Set of hands.
Maybe half-ish?
Not quite.
One of the things for
our numbers in terms
of what we see
broad enterprise is
that it's still relatively low.
So, again, you're
all here at Next.
So you're probably a little
bit ahead of the curve.
But it's an area that,
you know, actually
getting the
environment to support
that transition of dev
teams can be just as much
of a challenge in terms
of where this all winds up
moving forward and
how it can be managed.
To your point, you've
got to be able to bring
the rest of the organization
along when you get
to that journey, so
a little bit more
challenging in terms
of where that fits.
Now, one of the other things
I wanted to talk about,
time for the shark.
As well as desire, there's
also a lot of fear,
and we've talked a little bit
about what those concerns are,
but quite reasonably, when we
think about, especially network
infrastructure, there's a lot
of concern about what new models
can provide and
what the transition
risks are of being able to
move to those environments.
But a lot like
sharks, you know, this
happens to be a Caribbean
reef shark that is really
good for the reef ecosystem.
They don't really bother
people all that much.
But they look pretty scary.
They're still a shark.
And they are a
reasonably good metaphor
for what a lot of
these transitions
are because, I think,
a lot of organizations
look at what that transition
is, and all they see is change.
And change when it's
not well-defined,
when you don't understand
what's going to get you
to that new environment, can
be pretty scary for good reason
because you don't know what that
outcome is going to look like.
And there are more than
enough cautionary tales
that are out there.
People have seen things go
wrong when whatever happened.
I make the point
that a lot of this
might be tied to not being fully
aware of enough of the network
and interconnect
pieces that you've
got to have to be able to bring
that together, but leave it up
to [INAUDIBLE].
LAKSHMI SHARMA: I would say
that it is because people
don't really understand.
I mean, they understand the
current fate of designs.
They understand what have been
told to them, like, you know,
going from boxes on-prem
to boxes in cloud.
Like, say, hey, instead of
like I'll create your firewall,
but I'll keep it
like a box, right?
It will be still throttled
because of bandwidth.
A load balancer would still
be throttled by the bandwidth.
I think that's also because
they continue to be scared
because of those reasons.
But if they were told that the
shark is maybe like a gigantic
shark and then they don't--
they can't even move, it
will just stay globally
and would not really touch you.
It will help you, like,
what we have with,
you know, we do hear a the
time because we are so simple,
like, if people would have
really done the distributed
kind of SDN fabric
the we we have, like,
what we call Andromeda,
and Edge automation.
It's like truly self-edifying.
I know, I'm kind of--
I'm not looking at the shark
because I'm not afraid of it
because nobody--
when I came to Google
Cloud, like, it's just--
we just have very simple things
the way they're supposed to be.
And that's why people
wouldn't be scared,
but we want to be
able to explain
that how simple it
is and it should--
this is how it should have been.
Just because you have
global infrastructure,
just because you have
PoPs everywhere and fiber
everywhere, that
doesn't cause a risk,
and that doesn't
cost complexities
because the software which
is on top, it's simple.
It's really, you know,
logically-coordinated control
plane which is built to kind
of scale to the infrastructure
that we have.
So people-- it's just-- it's
so simple to understand.
And then that's how SDN
was supposed to be, right?
Like, you have a
logically-coordinated control
plane.
You put services on top.
So services are
also built the way
that application
developers are used to.
That's how this company built
the infrastructure, whether it
is an edge, whether you
talk about data center,
whether you talk about
like your cloud fabric,
it runs at the scale.
So I was talking to
somebody yesterday,
and they were asking
about the same thing.
Oh, you are so global.
Is it your infrastructure?
So people forget that
infrastructure is not just
hardware, and
edges, and routers.
Infrastructure capability
comes from the software
that we talk about.
That's what made cloud possible.
And if we would have made
that smaller in scale,
then there would be complexity.
We have taken all
those complexities out.
You just deploy--
click of a button.
Let's say you have
global load balancing.
You just go to one
place and configure it.
Then you go to-- if you want
to bring in your capabilities
like Cloud Armor, you
just go and configure
another click of a button.
Whether it is containers,
whether it is VM,
it is really like single point
of configuration management
and distributed to the
scale of the world.
And if people who
just visualize that,
I think they would
not be afraid of it.
ERIC HANSELMAN: Well, I
think one of the challenges
is that, you know,
we're all humans.
We see that doing the same
things that we've been doing
is the least risky
way to go forward.
And I think especially when
you start thinking about
our application structures
and interconnection,
that there's an expectation that
if we just simply take what we
had on-prem, put it into
new environments in exactly
the same way, it's just--
that's the safest way to do it.
You know, it's kind
of like walking
on the beach in dress shoes.
You can do that,
but you are going
to get sand in your shoes,
and it's really not the best
way to go about it.
You know, put on
flip-flops, get comfortable.
But for enterprises,
that first--
sort of it's that lift
and shift piece of,
we're going to take
exactly what we've got.
We're going to reproduce it
exactly the same way it was,
because we know that
works, without thinking
about a lot of the
simplifications that
can actually start to pull
out some of the complexity
because a lot of the way in
which the application has been
built and a lot of
those structures
work really well for the
technologies that were there.
But the simplifications
now start
to allow a much easier
management, better security,
better interconnection,
more than anything
else in new environments
can actually
start to help that
transition and can reduce
risk in that process as well.
That's, I think, one of the
things that many enterprises
tend to get stuck on is that
there is an expectation that we
simply have to reproduce it
exactly the way we did on-prem,
you know?
I've got a whole bunch of VLANs.
I need to match those
same VLAN connections
to exactly what
I've got, you know,
wherever I happen to be
despite the complexity of being
able to manage all those
tie-ins and the configuration
complexity that comes with it.
It's important to realize
that maintaining complexity
is also a risk factor.
And I know in a lot
of the conversations
we have with our clients,
the expectation that we just
keep things the way they are
misses out on an opportunity
to actually improve
their risk posture,
improve their security, reduce
errors in configuration.
Everybody's got good
statistics on how many outages
are caused simply by
manual error in some
of those transitions.
It can be a real
challenge in terms
of what really needs to happen.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: I've
used this analogy
before, you know, when I
worked in a previous job
that some cloud providers
who started keeping
the same notion as in terms of
manageability and operationals
at IT, when they
moved it to the cloud,
they really took the mainframe.
So clouds are-- not
for us, cloud providers
are the new mainframes
of the world, right?
So now once you're
stuck, you don't even
know where your storage is and
how-- where my policies are
managed, what kind of
visibility do I have?
Do I-- can I just use my
manageability and visibility
tools that I have?
Like, where is my packets
going, flow going?
So all that visibility
and manageability
around my information, like,
say, in this case, VPC,
or in this case, your
resources, is not
easy to offer because
it's just a new mainframe
for some providers, not for us.
ERIC HANSELMAN: Well, and
you bring up the point
about operational visibility,
which is another critical part.
You know, the move
to virtualization
gave organizations a
lot more visibility
in terms of what was
actually happening
in the infrastructure.
The move to cloud
actually increases
that dramatically further.
But most organizations
don't take advantage of it.
In many cases, because
they're not actually set up
to be able to leverage
greater visibility to be
able to take all that telemetry
and actually digest it, which
actually brings me to the next
point I wanted to identify,
which is that there is a
dramatic lack of automation.
If we think about what
organizations are doing today,
we've got to get more
automated in ways
that are more sophisticated.
But having lots of
additional telemetry
that can give you information
about what's happening
is great.
But in many cases,
we keep running
with the same
procedures that have
got strong manual dependencies.
And this is particularly
true in networking.
And it's one of
those things that I
think is, for me, one of those
big transitional opportunities
that you can actually start to
do a lot more in terms of both
the capabilities you have, the
awareness you have in terms
of the amount of telemetry
that's coming out
of those environments,
and the ways
in which you can
put it to work to,
again, simplify what you're
doing day in and day out.
So--
LAKSHMI SHARMA: That's
an interesting piece.
So we used to hear and like even
before I joined this company,
other places, hey, cloud can
only offer you L3 visibility,
or it can give you, like, maybe
end-of-the-day information
about all your applications.
So to be able to get like,
say, traditional net flow
[INAUDIBLE] fixed of
information as well as you
can get like your
L3 information.
So a combination
of that was kind
of what enterprises had been
asking for, or customers
had been asking for.
In that space, I mean, you
know, some products which
we call VPC flow
logs, which gives you
a combination of both.
And it will continue to
integrate with your existing CM
infrastructure.
So if you're used to
using certain tools
for just digesting
that information
and doing troubleshooting--
so we have received
a lot of good feedback because
we have been able to understand
that, yes, you do
want to as I said,
natural information
of your IP flows.
And at the same
time, you do want--
like, where is my--
where is it coming from
and what my IP address is
like the L3 plus application
information.
So we do have some--
we heard that feedback,
and we are bringing up--
we have brought up some products
like that in that space.
ERIC HANSELMAN:
Well, because it's
critical to being able
to effectively manage
your environment.
I think a lot of
of organizations
tend to sort of layer on a lot
of that monitoring management
capability, again, especially
the networking side.
And being able to have
your environment actually
provide it for you,
again, simplifies
what you can do with it
and how you manage it.
Curious in terms of the
environment that's here.
How many of you are
using more NetFlow--
well, things like network
management capabilities
like NetFlow and
other telemetry to be
able to give you real-time
information about how
your environments are operating?
You know, a lot of
organizations we work with.
A handful.
OK.
So we're getting
there in good shape.
A lot of the capabilities that
next-stage environments provide
can really help you get to
greater levels of visibility
and also greater
levels of integration
when you talk about identity tie
ins and some of those pieces.
When you start
looking at automation,
that becomes an even bigger
piece of that environment
and where that fits.
I also want to make
sure that if there
any questions that were
going over any of this,
we're also happy to
take questions as well.
So anything that we've
raised or anything that
doesn't fit today?
No?
All right, well,
I want to push on
to one of the other pieces
about network automation
and what is it that
holds people back.
Network automation is, by its
nature, harder than compute.
And this is a--
back up here.
And that's due to the
fact that the impact
and the effect of
network automation
is very different than compute.
It must be the shark pressing
the button, I don't know.
If you think about
compute, we got
really good at doing
compute automation
because compute is
relatively isolated.
The challenge is
doing it at scale.
You've got to be able to do
lots of whatever that automation
piece is.
But you're actually only working
on small, reasonably atomic
pieces of infrastructure
when you actually manage it.
Network turns that
whole thing on its head.
Networking automation is much
more complicated, and, I think,
gets viewed as more
risky because of the fact
that network
configuration changes,
much like managing slides,
has a much broader effect.
You've got-- you make a
network configuration change.
And there are a whole set of
potentially connected devices
that are tied to it.
It means that there's
a lot more perceived
risk around network automation.
The real paradox to my
mind is that here you've
got an environment in
which there is risk,
but yet there's still
really low automation.
And automation would get you to
the point at which you actually
can reduce risk because you're
doing fewer manual operations.
So it's one of these
crazy situations when we
think about how you manage it.
But there's a
significant opportunity
when you move towards
new environments
to be able to leverage
native capabilities
to actually automate away
much of that manual process
amongst those capabilities.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: I
think complexity,
in some cases, come from,
yes, network is global.
It's there.
It seamless.
And I'll go back to the
example from the shark,
like, hey, this is--
here is the DNS.
Here is the CDN provider.
Here is your API.
Here is your API gateway.
And it will--
everybody just talks--
starts from because
it is hybrid,
because it is multi-cloud.
Let's just do federation
here, federation here,
federation here.
This will have different
configurations.
I feel like that's
also-- and I will go back
to my kind of example of,
if you think about services
as application running
on top of an SDN fabric,
that's how SDN and cloud
automation was supposed to be.
So they are just kind of
adding services as and when
you deploy, and you can take
those services in a managed
fashion as well, right?
Some of the things around
Istio, for example,
they were meant to kind
of abstract the service
plane, which sits on
top of networking plane.
But if you do not simplify
your network control plane,
you won't be able to
get the scalability out
of your application.
So they both need to
continue to go hand-in-hand.
And other reasons
based on my experience
of working with telcos and
enterprises has been there
are so many contracts to write.
If you talk about I'm going
from one region or one country
to another country,
you're talking
about [INAUDIBLE] You're
talking about writing
three months, four
months, spending
time on legal contracts of
how not just about data,
just about policies, right?
So if we could just
take that away,
which we do, to our
global VPCs, and you
don't have to really worry
about all of that contracting,
and peering, and all of
that because somebody
has taken care of
you for that view.
And you just worry about
adding your application
and then discovering your
application wherever you are.
You know, some of the complexity
to the automation that you
talked about does go away.
ERIC HANSELMAN:
Well, and I think
that's one of the
challenges to automation
is that when we have a
really complex environment,
the automation task winds
up being that much more
challenging.
What you have to build around
it is more complicated to build.
If you've got the
ability to simplify it--
and Istio is a great example--
now you've got the
ability to leverage
what are built-in
capabilities that
simply remove that complexity.
How many of the crowd here are
actually using Istio today?
It has now officially gone
1.0, but it's been out there
for a while in terms of--
I've got a handful of folks who
are playing with Istio already?
The whole idea
about service meshes
is one of, again, these next
steps of simplifications
that can help move you to
environments that are going
to be better suited to hybrid
infrastructures that will help
to abstract away a
lot of the complexity
that you get when you're moving
towards environments that give
you a lot of choice and
a lot of flexibility
in terms of where you're headed.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: So
making transitions--
it's not really the network.
It's because the
network is just there.
So the transition that happens
if through that transition
journey, if you can keep
the paradigm same maybe,
like in the--
reduce it all with the
automation and the tools
and just allow your
customers or your enterprises
to not just develop faster, but
continue to update faster too.
I hear a lot of
numbers about, hey,
you can write like 2,000
deployments in a day.
But [INAUDIBLE] if you have to--
if I want to bring you like
a lot of features every day,
I want to make sure that my
automation and orchestration
continue to support
that development,
upgrades needs to be
faster too, right?
ERIC HANSELMAN: Absolutely.
Well, to get to
that level of speed,
you've got to simplify what your
operational capabilities are.
You can't have complicated
systems that are running.
So, again, a great way to be
able to manage that and work
that transition.
One of the other points
I wanted to bring up,
and this is actually
the last slide in terms
of what some of the data
is that I've got up here,
and this is one of
the ones that I think
concerns me most about
this most recent study.
This is something that came
out of the field just a couple
of months ago, which is
the budget that's typically
being allocated.
If we take a look
at what's happening
in terms of expectation of
spending, I think right now,
a lot of the fear about what
transitions and risk are
presenting to people are
actually holding back
expectations of spending.
This is something that, from
a value to organizations,
is something that you've got to
be willing to be able to budget
to be able to make
this transition
because there are
going to be shifts
in terms of where that fits.
If we think about what
the expectation is
in terms of spending on
transformation and investment
in the infrastructure
and how that actually
gets transitioned, these
are things that, you know,
you've got a
relatively small number
that are looking at spending
significantly enough to be
able to get to the
infrastructure support that's
going to need--
that they're going to need
to be able to get there.
And I think a lot of this winds
up being driven by concerns
that I don't want to invest in
something that I see as risky.
And that's going to-- but
the challenge there is then
that that holds
off what actually
are the capabilities that
are going to enable you
to get to where you need to be.
And that presents
some difficulties.
This is something where
you don't have to go all-in
in terms of
transformation, but you
do need to make the
effort to be able to get
to a point at which you can
operate more efficiently.
And you can leverage a
lot of these capabilities.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: So it's not
just-- so this specific slide
is about how much budget
on the transformation side,
but the budget could still be
spent on the operational side.
So we still have kind of--
you can still go and help
out by operationalizing,
keeping like--
extending in a seamless way,
and giving all the tools,
but that budget still exists?
OK.
ERIC HANSELMAN: Not
getting rid of anything.
But to get there, the thing
that I think both Lakshmi
and I have been really
trying to reinforce
is that the fundamental
aspect of this
is that you've got to get
to a point at which you
can be more efficient.
Being able to move towards
new environments is powerful.
There are a tremendous
set of things
that it helps to bring to the
way in which the organization
can potentially
operate, but it's
something where you've got to
be able to ensure that people
and processes are supported with
capabilities underneath this
as well.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: So simplify
operations like we--
with tools like the
Kubernetes Engine
that we support and automation,
automation end to end.
So all the world that
is happening in Istio
and managing services across.
So that, as well as
like the combination
that I talked about,
like, VPC service control
where you integrate all the
way from edge to the core
through identity all the way to
your VPC resources and managed
services and managing all
those abstractions around that.
So it seems like, you
know-- so we have--
in networking, we have
a lot of good tools.
And then there lot
of talks where--
please go today.
There are sessions around
end-to-end security from edge
to data center, edge to code.
And how do we connect
that through the identity
with proxies?
And then we talk about logical
association and application
group thing, like, we have a lot
of products around application
delivery, like load balancer,
global load balancer and Cloud
Armor.
There's a lot of things
around application grouping
as well as the security
aspects, rather.
And it's really managed through
the seminal abstractions
and I would rather say
that infrastructure
that is built over years.
So one is from, how
do you access that?
But at the same time, for
us, our infrastructure
is designed that way too.
So if you talk about things
coming from [INAUDIBLE] that
hit our GFE, and it
just kind of-- it
supports our global
load balancer,
which supports like
products like Cloud Armor.
So we are organize-- our
infrastructure ways-- also,
we are designed that way.
And we do have software that
puts abstractions on top.
And we do continue to
kind of make investment
through the open source world.
And open source supports
hybrid and multi-cloud too.
ERIC HANSELMAN:
Well, and that can
smooth that path for
enterprises to be
able to make that
transition and to be
able to get to that point.
It's important to think
about not only the automation
pieces, but how that actually
affects operation as a whole.
And to your point,
it's simplifying
all those operations, being
able to go bring that together
with a set of tools that
enterprises can typically
consume, and the ability to be
able to bring that all in ways
that leveraged hybrid
infrastructure can help
to make that transition
as painless as possible,
but more importantly,
to reduce risk
in that transition
at the same time.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: And hybrid does
mean that multi-cloud as well,
right?
So we can help customers go
from one cloud to another.
ERIC HANSELMAN:
Yeah, as analysts,
we've got very specific
definitions for some things,
but the reality is hybrid
environments are simply
a matter of multiple clouds,
multiple capabilities,
but the important
thing is to understand
how you're going to
run that environment
and operationalize it.
The points that
you're identifying
are big pieces of making
that transition simple
from an enterprise perspective.
And I think you were
mentioning that this afternoon,
there's also going to
be a little bit of--
LAKSHMI SHARMA: Yes.
ERIC HANSELMAN:
--some more surprises
in the networking
track later on today.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: That's correct.
So there's a session
this afternoon
coming up on how there is--
how we are defining
some constructs
in networking,
where you would be
able to leverage them
and get like native load
balancing in a hybrid way.
And when I say hybrid, to
me, hybrid is like the point
that I touched upon.
It's multi-cloud and hybrid
across infrastructure
like doing load balancing, the
highest latency, and the best
bandwidth optimization for
VMs as well as for containers.
So there are some
very-- you know,
things we are going
to launch, and we
are going to talk about, to make
this very simple, operationally
same, regardless of what
infrastructure and what
location do you
choose and bringing
all the power of like what
we talked about like CDN,
and, you know, TLS support
from multiple certificates,
and things that
we have been doing
in the face of global
load balancing.
We will bring all of that to
support multi-cloud and hybrid.
So if you plan to attend
or want to hear about that,
please refer to some of
our Kubernetes sessions.
And there will be-- and as well
as like end-to-end security
sessions.
So with that, thank you so much.
And thank you everybody
for attending.
If you have some
questions, we will be
around for a few minutes here.
So with that, thank you again.
Thanks a lot.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]